in this lecture we will concentrate on
the study of Markov chains in the long
run and study under what conditions a
Markov chain exhibits steady-state
behavior under the what conditions such
steady-state behavior is independent of
the initial starting state more
precisely we will look at long-term
state occupancy behavior that is in the
N step transition probabilities when n
is large so for example assume that we
have a Markov chain which is initially
in a given state I and consider the
probability that the chain is in a
specific state J after n transitions
question does that probability converge
to some constant when n goes to infinity
second question and if this is the case
can this constant be independent of the
initial state I we will see that for
nice Markov chains the answer to both
questions will be yes how to
characterize nice Markov chains we will
use several new concepts one dealing
with the Markov chain being a cyclic or
not and the other with the notion of
recurrent classes without going into
details now let us simply mention that
we will show that the existence of
convergence will be tied to having an a
cyclic Markov chain and in case we have
convergence the independence from the
initial state will be tied to having a
single recurrent class we will end this
lecture by looking in details at a
special and important class of Markov
chains usually known as birth-death
processes